[Music]
I'm going to tell you about a person and
the story surrounding her is going to
have two twists to it oh my god let's do
is this a personal story what do you
mean like are they alive no it's not me
a personal story stories have Twisted
you sound like you're about to like
disallow me from saying it don't even
say it yeah so this is the story of
somebody called mil lover AK a Bailey St
Clair wait hold on dude mil FL that's
twist number one who the [__] it's a guy
mil lover 5,000 and she's a mil lover
lovely lovely girl and her name is MIL
she yeah man yeah that makes so come on
you you'd be high five in this girl is
she a mil like I'm the mil lover she's
not a mil she's 19 she likes mil she
likes mil she why not what do you not
maybe it's men I'd like to [__] wait so
she's a lesbian see variation very very
confusing all right so um luuv in August
of
2023 she was the passenger in a car that
was being driven by an intoxicated
person that uh crashed on the Texas
Highway she got ejected out of the car
um as it slammed into another car wow
police reported that her injuries were
so extremely critical that she was not
expected to survive oh dear Lord that's
just so scary among multiple broken
bones
and being completely immobilized and she
had a a brain bleed her road rash was so
severe that they she had to be treated
by the Burn Unit wa Jesus see that's why
they say wear helmets and padding dude
don't go out there always wear while
you're driving in your car wear football
pads hey if it's cool enough for F1
drivers to do it then it's cool enough
for you that's why they say always
install a a roll cage in your uh Camry
my dad took ours out for a subwoofer so
the crazy thing is she ends up going in
the hospital obviously and then uh about
a month in intensive care her family um
they needed to get her air lifted to
Oregon cuz that's where she like lives
her family's at D that must have been a
long flight yeah and it cost Texas to
Oregon while you're injured expensive
yeah it cost like I think the quote was
like upwards of like 60k just to move
her oh my God cuz they use a helicopter
Yeah well yeah I didn't know helicopters
came organ the long range heli imagine
they're like airlifting is going to cost
a lot cuz we use a helicopter and they
just poke your head like helicopter
helicopter helicopter helicopter yeah
super super expensive yeah cuz you're
pretty much booking a private flight
with a private nurse and doctor on the
flight right right right they have uh
Hospital private flights I didn't know
that cuz you have you have uh like
flight nurses but it's like a it's like
a bus though you got to wait for all the
injured people to get
on everyone walking their IV bags like
hurry up and they wait they and they and
they actually take all of your IVs and
stuff like that and they put it in that
little the storage area and they have to
configurate all of it we'll pass it back
down sit down first yeah so I think at
this point she's still like pretty
immobile can't really do anything um and
yeah that set them back a ton having to
to pay for the air lifting and all of
the medical expenses and everything uh
twist number one the person I'm talking
about is actually a massive longtime JK
fan no way mil lover yeah baile we
should have known dude with the name
like that JK fan that's why I was like a
girl with the name mil lover is pretty
cool yeah dude it's pretty cool here's a
message from her she was saying what the
[__] dude so she got this message to us
um about a month ago and it uh said said
hey I don't know if you check messages
from fans I've been a fan over 5 years
and I thought about writing a letter I
don't know how long those go without
being read but maybe I will anyways uh
since my accident I had a
0.005% chance of
survival um in the ICU when I didn't
know who I was I remembered you guys and
wanted to watch even with seven of my
bones being out that was the first thing
you remember she wakes up she goes Nick
the
ear or Anthony anon's a
911 she's like [__] kjas I don't know
why I said that I don't even know who
they are what date where are you and
then she's all like oh just kidding news
just kidding news careful boys they're
very give me some ker bag that's pretty
cool milk lover is [__]
cool one more Nick one more that's all I
got that's all I got I need a k b got we
got to get these out it's been a while
guy has a black Bel for one week should
send her some [__] dude yeah she goes
watching does she does she have a Gund
me or something that that's that's for
her uh bills and all that it at the end
we need to we need to put that [__] up
said um point is now that I'm in a
healthier State uh life can still be
hard at times but watching you guys
always puts a smile on my face and gives
me a sense of normaly back thank you
seriously it means the world to me and
then like um I kind of kept in
correspondence with her for a little bit
uh November 30 she sent this and she
took her very first steps wow that's
[__] incredible are we going to put
that in the videos yeah no we're not
we're going to blur it
out give that footage to K so people can
see this miracle happening motivated by
JK news oh my God bro that's [__]
incredible she's like this is one step
for me and one step for Nick dun and one
step for Anthony Lee and one step for B
clown this would have been great promo
if we already had the fear everyone
socks
said let's commercialize her
[__] page yeah turn it into
merch yeah you could buy the first steps
t-shirt right here exactly
it have a a profile of her walking and
then she's walking towards a computer
monitor so she can watch more
JK the channel trailer blur it
out do you know how many um fans have
DME from the [__] Hospital whether
they're dealing with cancer they're
dealing with like crazy accidents some
[__] crazy ass autoimmune disease
whatever it is right it's always like
this weird oh I don't got [__] to do so
I'm just going to watch JK and then I'm
like why why are we the two go people
maybe it's like it makes them happy cuz
they're laughing and they forget their
pain dude when you're at your lowest low
you got to see a bunch of other people
that are also low that's maybe what it
is it's like jery Springer low
recognized low hey new t-shirt new
t-shirt lowest of the lows I was I was
telling I was telling the I was telling
I was telling Barton nick uh yesterday I
wouldn't be surprised um if one day like
a courier walks in here with a cake and
then he's like got this big [__] cake
and he throws it up in the air and drops
it or whatever and then and then
everyone's like oh no and then Joe's
like don't worry we can clean up with
these JK
towels and we're like of course cleans
up all the messiest spills
you get free stickers with this purchase
they'd probably be JK throwback towels
too got the uncles and all
that let's do it JK TOS is a good idea
oh oh see I do it oh Joe Joe Joe are you
ready for this the wall holes turn them
into vinyl wall decals and everyone can
have their own
H wouldn't you want to be between the
butt cheeks of our fans like your face
and you can do it with a JK towel have
all six of us in your ass cheeks when
you wash oh man that's the use a towel
to wash your [__] after the wash
after the shower after you do the floss
so she says thank you I'm so stupid
happy now and what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger I will say my sense
of humor has only gotten darker of
course dude you go through some crazy
[__] jokes about the situation than pout
wow isn't that that's [__] so cool
mil flover aw Bailey love it's crazy
that she goes through this crazy ordeal
and she's such a nice person that her
first thing is she wants to give us a
lot of like flowers it's like I know
what a great person what a nice person
holy [__] yeah I asked her like a like
just three questions about it I said how
did it feel like waking up after the
crash he said apparently I was conscious
after the crash but have no recollection
until weeks following wow she wasn't
consciously there for a while um in the
ICU she just said she remembers feeling
really grateful to be alive but
heartbroken and overall
confused uh another question I asked was
have you been able to stay positive she
said she goes to therapy twice weekly
and her best friend's been there for her
and uh she has coping mechanisms like
baking cooking um art class sounds very
productive and then I asked her like are
there other like um non-related problems
that you're dealing with alongside the
physical recovery cuz you know like life
doesn't stop when something happens to
you like a bunch of things keep going
and she said she's lost relationships
with family members um because of what
she's gone through um like they
abandoned her ass yeah because she kind
of elaborated and said that I guess like
at the time she this was in Texas when
this happened so I guess she was with
maybe like I I don't know if it's a
boyfriend or a friend or something and
um you know like when [__] like this
happens and everyone gets shaken up
after the dust settles a little bit then
people start pointing fingers and like
what were you even doing why were you
doing that you know [__] up dude yeah
and then everyone's going to have their
opinion and so like she she you
shouldn't have been a the girlfriend in
the first place you shouldn't be in that
rehab [__] there's way way better
methodologies to use all this [__] and
it sounds like it sounds like there's
actually like a pretty complex thing
going on where like it was her boyfriend
that she was visiting in Texas and at
the same time like she's saying that his
he was um like being abusive to her like
so there's like a whole thing where it's
like people are blaming her for even
being in this position
it really sucks to have to hear all that
where you're just trying to all your
fault he had to beat you up man I can't
even walk right now dude yeah really
yeah so she's having like other
difficulties too but uh you know we're
here for you Bailey thank you for uh
100% for messaging us and uh put up your
go I'm going to put money in your
GoFundMe yeah guys if you guys are
watching if you want to help out uh
Bailey St Clair we're going to put her
GoFundMe Link in the bio down below um
let's all support as a JK fans put her
IG up too if you guys want to send her
little hello or some like words of
encouragement uh super cool she's really
just like us really great dark humor
here she is wearing a a hoodie that just
says human
Cannonball human
cannon yeah she's great hey we should
start selling that make some money off
of
it we give her 5% put more money in her
Gund me that's what we're doing crash
test dummy shirts
yeah and don't be alarmed if merch comes
out with your face on it we own it it's
your like we should have her we own it
it's in this video getting like a cars
here and then she's launching out of the
car and then she's like this like that
that's pretty sick that'll be real cool
that's pretty sick she got a JK shirt on
yes and it it says fear everyone and
while we make money off it we'll send
her a
towel she would love towel happy healing
Bailey St Clair
hey